I have the biggest goalposts move maybe
of all time and politics to tell you
about today and it has to do with our
buddy Rudy Giuliani Donald Trump's one
of Trump I guess at this point he has 17
18 20 lawyers it's not even clear what
the total number is one of those lawyers
is Rudy Giuliani and Rudy Giuliani is
now saying he never said there was no
Russian collusion I have the clip for
you and this is now at historically
pathetic and and pretty embarrassing
levels so let's think back to the
beginning right don't forget that from
the beginning we were told there will be
no Russia investigation when one started
we were told the investigation is gonna
end quickly it's not going to uncover
any wrongdoing once the investigation
found that actually people did break the
law we will - we were told well no one's
going to be convicted but of course then
people were convicted and at that point
the new goalposts move was well the
convictions all or four things that took
place before the 2016 election and they
don't have anything to do with Russia or
the Trump campaign but then of course
that imploded and I'm skipping over like
a dozen other intermediate lies but most
recently we learned that Donald Trump's
campaign manager I'm sorry campaign
chairman Paul Manafort was directly
giving polling data and other data to
Russians at minimum never mind
everything else that we've learned and
continue to learn so that gets us to
yesterday and at this point we have Rudy
Giuliani Donald Trump's attorney saying
on live television to CNN's Chris Cuomo
he never denied that there was collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia he
just meant Trump wasn't personally
colluding take a look at this and if
you're watching pay particular attention
to the expression on Chris Cuomo face as
Judy Giuliani denies having denied
something that he actually denied
countless times that there was collusion
stunned and perplexed doesn't even begin
to cover Chris Cuomo's expression take a
look I'm they did that where the amount
of false reporting about this case is
despicable sir mr. mayor false reporting
is saying that nobody in the campaign
had any contacts with Russia false
reporting is saying that there has
no suggestion of any kind of collusion
between the campaign and any Russians
because now you have Paul Manafort
giving poll data I never wind up leading
to this coincidence misstated my
position I never said there was no
collusion between the campaign or
between people in the campaign I have
not I said the president United States
there is not a single bit of evidence
the president United States committed
the only crime you could admit here
conspired with the Russians to half the
DNC first of all crime is not the core
of a count of I really hope that like
many of his other employees Trump's not
paying Rudy Giuliani that he's been
ignoring his legal bills because this is
just embarrassing what Rudy Giuliani is
doing now so the new story is sure
plenty of campaign people colluded with
Russia but Trump personally never
colluded with Russia
no one colluded with Russia except for
Trump's campaign chairman the deputy
campaign chairman trunks Trump's
longtime personal attorney Michael Cohen
and a whole bunch of other smaller
players but what we meant all along when
we said no collusion was that it's Trump
who didn't collude what TV channels
should really be preparing for these
interviews is clips of people saying
stuff so that when they deny it they can
just go right to it when Rudy Giuliani
says I never denied that there was
collusion they could go right to a
supercut of him denying collusion of
Trump to Trump denying that anyone
colluded and get him to react to that
here's just one example of this okay
there they could have dozens of these
ready here's just one example oh you're
not wrong but Russia collusion was wrong
with Donald Trump Russian collusion is a
total fake news unfortunately it has
become the basis of the investigation
right but now he claims it's not
something that he has ever denied we've
reached that stage okay there was no
collusion
- there was no collusion but it wouldn't
be a crime anyway - we never said there
was no collusion and when Rudy Giuliani
goes on TV and moves the goalposts like
this to me it signals something big is
about to break Pat and they're trying to
get ahead of it because you know what
tomorrow is
tomorrow is Muller grand-jury Friday and
so far every time we've seen Giuliani do
something like this it's in advance of
something terrible breaking I honestly
think though that even if the news team
had those cliffs ready disproving what
Rudy Giuliani is saying showing that yes
you did deny Trump Russia collusion I
think he would just respond by saying
the truth isn't the truth he would move
the goalposts even even further
that's how pathetic this has got and
Sean Hannity on the other hand he takes
a different approach wraps it all up as
a conspiracy a deep state conspiracy
these are the different approaches that
they're taking right now and it's
getting really really probably right
that even if you present a Giuliani with
the clips he would come up with
something argue the videos been doctored
or it was taken out of context or
whatever and this is why politics is so
toxic and our elected officials and the
system that that we have have such low
approval ratings because any normal
person at this point would obviously
have been indicted for their involvement
in a criminal conspiracy to collude with
Russia and to cover it up with
obstruction of justice with witness
tampering with the entire thing but as
the president you have the benefit of
Fox News and a right-wing media
apparatus defending your every move all
the time period no matter what you do
you have lawyers like Rudy Giuliani
moving the goalposts so far that they're
off the field and into the parking lot
it's really simple we can tell what is
right and wrong here everything about
this is wrong and any normal person
would have been indicted already but
it's absolutely not guaranteed that
there will be any consequences for the
top people involved because we have two
justice systems in this country as I've
talked about many many times before